tras el alto al fuego el silencio y la
devastación
los supervivientes a los 11 días de
ataques aéreos de israel sobre gaza
buscan la manera de seguir adelante no
estoy de acuerdo con esta tregua que
significa regresamos a nuestras casas no
tenemos donde sentarnos no tenemos agua
ni electricidad ni camas nada acciones
unidas pide al gobierno israelí y a la
organización de hamás que respeten la
tregua para que pueda seguir circulando
la ayuda humanitaria que empezó a entrar
en la franja tras el cese de las
hostilidades gay hoy 13 camiones con
ayuda humanitaria con comida vacunas
contra el kobe 19 material médico
medicinas incluyendo fármacos de
emergencia y kits de primeros auxilios
entraron en gaza con la reapertura
parcial del paso de kerem shalom proxy
naciones unidas anunció un plan de 18 6
millones de dólares para la
reconstrucción de la zona acordada con
israel y la autoridad nacional palestina
eeuu también comunicó su colaboración en
términos humanitarios una cooperación
controlada para que no llegue a manos de
hamás sin embargo la ayuda material no
puede reparar toda la destrucción
aquí había un edificio aquí me acabo de
encontrar con el padre y la hija de una
familia de siete los otros cinco
miembros han muerto no son solo daños en
infraestructuras sino pérdidas de
familias enteras he estado hablando con
muchas familias y todos dicen que no
tienen esperanza sienten que no tienen
el control de sus vidas el consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas se emitió
este sábado su primera declaración
unánime desde que empezaron los ataques
pidió la plena adhesión al cese el fuego
de las dos partes tres intentos
anteriores de resoluciones exigiendo el
fin de las hostilidades y el respeto por
la vida de civiles fueron bloqueadas por
eeuu